[Musique]
je pense que le plus important
aujourd'hui c'est d'être entendu et
surtout comprend compris parce que
malheureusement aujourd'hui beaucoup de
candidats écoute sans vraiment
comprendre
robert hue bonjour bonjour vous ne
pensez pas que ce sentiment de ne pas
être entendus les citoyennes et des
citoyens l'ont encore plus lors de cette
élection présidentielle si ça se
comprend depuis le début on explique aux
français qu'on leur demande aux rien
sauf à choisir entre deux candidats
désignés en avance il donc
incompréhensible dans ces conditions que
google soit dans une situation de
désintérêt par rapport à l'élection ou
soit dans la recherche d'un vote de
refus mais je veux le dire clairement il
y as danger car les choix qui vont être
faits après cette élection vont
concerner directement la vie de chacune
et de chacun
qu'est ce qui peut peser sur ses choix
s'abstenir se limiter à protester ou
bien faire en sorte que ceux qui
marquent cette élection ce soit le refus
de la politique de la droite et du grand
patronat
ce soit le rejet de l'extrême droite ce
soit l'exigence que la gauche mène
demain une politique plus à gauche pour
faire mieux
des mesures d'urgence contre le chômage
la précarité les injustices et
discriminations de toutes sortes des
réformes pour se dégager de la
domination de l'argent roi
pour que la france travaille à
transformer l'europe et le monde
ce ne sont pas des mots c'est ce que la
gauche peut faire demain 2 dont nous la
force par le vote du 21 avril de
l'exiger et cette fois d'être entendu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]